welcome back to the Hillsdale College
Constitution Town Hall we're now having
journey through the Constitution from
the founders to the Civil War at present
day some have referred to our
present-day
condition as living in an administrative
state but nonetheless citizens continue
to have very important duties what are
those duties were very pleased that
hills dales president dr. Larry Arn will
be speaking in our final concluding
session today dr. honors the author of
Liberty and learning the evolution of
American education you can find more
information about this book on the
Hillsdale website to introduce dr. Arne
Hillsdale College student corinne
rhombic a junior at Hillsdale she's
interning this semester at Freedom Works
where she's the Holiday Army Freedom
Works scholar crin thank you dr. Bob it
is my honor to make this introduction
Larry P Arne is the 12th president of
Hillsdale College he received his BA
from Arkansas State University
graduating with the highest distinction
he received an MA in government and a
PhD in government from the Claremont
Graduate School he also studied in
England from 1977 to 1980 first as a
research student in international
history at the London School of
Economics and then in modern history at
Worcester College Oxford University
while in England he also served as the
director of research for Martin Gilbert
now Sir Martin of Merton College Oxford
and the official biographer of Winston
Churchill he returned to the United
States in 1980 to become an editor for
public research syndicated and from 1985
to 2000 he served as president of the
Claremont Institute an education and
research institution institution based
in Southern California while at
Claremont he was the founding chairman
of the California Civil Rights
initiative which was passed by
California voters in 1996 and prohibited
racial preferences in state hiring
contracting and admissions dr. Arnn is
on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Army War College
the Henry Salvatori center of Claremont
McKenna College and the Claremont
Institute published widely in national
newspapers magazines and periodicals on
issues of Public Policy history
and political theory he is the author of
liberty and learning the evolution of
American education published by
Hillsdale College Press in 2004 this
afternoon he will speak on the topic the
administrative state and the duties of
citizens please join me in welcoming dr.
iron thank you Korean thank you all very
much
Corinne says she was nervous coming up
here because it's got to be false but
she says I have a reputation for making
fun of the students at Hillsdale College
and I would never do that but I do have
to confess you that that you may think
that this parade of students who come up
here are chosen because they're better
looking and smarter than the average
because they do seem you know pretty
good-looking and smart but know these
are the dumbest on the ugliest ones ha
ha her parents are probably watching
Corinne is I've known Curran since she
was a freshman she's a marvel and thank
you very much and thank David and the
faculty members and the people at
worldwide TV here who organized this for
us
I do members this morning that did such
a fine job I it was reminded maybe I'm
not needed here as you heard from Korean
I've spent a lot of time studying
Winston Churchill and sometimes he would
decline to go to a thing or give a
speech because he said somebody really
good was going and he said if you keep a
dog you don't necessarily have to bark
yourself
Thank You RJ and Paul and David and all
of them Matt Spalding an old friend of
mine too well hey mostly I want to thank
you people in the audience here and the
people on the Internet
because this is a time of very great
danger in our country and it's almost an
arithmetic or logical fact that it goes
along with danger that there's
opportunity there too and we have some
marvelous opportunities in front of us
and that has so much to do with the
attitude and the activity of the
American people in these days they are
troubled and they are doing things and
they are active and they are thinking
and it's with the thinking that I hope
to help we hope to help today it is our
purpose at Hillsdale College founded in
1844 to help with thinking I'll tell you
a little bit about the college in a
minute but mostly what I want to do
today is just three things I want to
summarize what's been said so far
quickly I want to make a few
recommendations about what we do and I
want to give one example and then we'll
be done and I look forward to answering
your question don't go fast the summary
is really in three points one is why are
we in trouble today as I said what's
wrong today what's going on and I will
argue in a couple of ways today that the
important thing to understand about the
Constitution is not this and that
particular part of it although each part
of it is terribly important it's not a
very long document and it's clear and it
means what it says but the structure the
grand meaning of the document has been
lost and that's where we're in trouble
and I'm going to state that grand
structure in a very simple way in the
Federalist Papers James Madison says
that this is the first purely
representative form of government ever
founded what does that mean purely
representative why is that important why
is that significant
Madison lived in a world in which there
had never been such a thing as this
because the location of sovereignty
sovereignty means the legitimate title
to rule is in an odd place in our
country in England which of course was
very much on their minds
the king was sovereign and he was the
executive branch of government and so
the sovereign got up every morning and
ran the government that's changed by the
way over time now the king is formerly
sovereign but the real sovereign in
England is the people acting under a
constitution of which the king is the
symbol but that happened after our
arrangements were completed here in the
United States in Athens the people were
sovereign and when there was a law to be
passed they met to pass it in the United
States of America the constitutional
majority says Lincoln shifting easily
with time and circumstance is the only
true sovereign of a free people and in
our country we do not occupy any part of
the government and that means our only
way to influence it is through elections
that's why elections are so important in
our country and when I say that there's
a danger that the location of
sovereignty might be adjusted what I
mean is the government itself has become
a force large enough to be influential
in elections both by a direct regulation
of elections campaigns are now very
closely regulated although I'm happy to
report less closely regulated than they
were a week ago before the Supreme Court
made its decision and and it's notorious
that these regulations are contrived in
a contest to pick who wins and loses one
of the reasons for them but for the
support from the mccain-feingold said on
the floor of Congress by several
different people was that there's
there's too much unfair criticism of
people in office around election time
and you know dang it I can I can see why
that would just be terribly annoying and
they were gonna you know sort that out a
little bit but if if sovereignty is
outside but then elections you know
think somebody what are we all afraid of
today by the way it's in the paper it's
in every Tea Party report it's and
everything you see people are afraid
that they might be about to lose control
and the specific way they would lose
control if they did is that elections
would not be able to make any change any
more isn't the most common complaint you
hear going around the country and you
know I have the blessing and the curse
of going around the country a lot in my
life and you should watch that movie up
in the air it's an excellent account of
what it's like to travel on airplanes
all the time and the skills that one
acquires to try to do it that guy was a
bit better at it than I am but you're
not completely better and what do you
learn when you go around people thinking
is it really true now that what a lot of
us think doesn't matter anymore because
there's an established force and it
cannot be influenced anymore and you
heard RJ post read Oh make the argument
that it was part of the purpose after
all to make the administrative
establishment permanent in ways that
would not be subject to alteration
through politics and if it becomes true
then that the ultimate title to rule in
the country passes from the people into
the government that would actually be
worse than living in a monarchy or a
direct democracy because we don't really
have any constitutional structure to
protect us from such a thing like that
we're not designed that way it would be
a kind of a collapse that would be very
dangerous and very hard to recover from
so that's why there's a crisis in my
opinion and the second reason there's a
crisis is why is that happening and I
think the force behind this movement is
worse than the movement itself if it can
be
because you've heard this description of
this thing called progressivism and and
by the way it isn't controversial the
founders of that movement were
explicitly in rebellion against the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence and specifically explicitly
and over and over again in rebellion
against the basic structure of the
Constitution they say that write and
analyze that argument for a minute and
I'll just make two points about it the
first is there are two ways to approach
the question of power in one way the
question is the first question to answer
is what should I do look at the
Declaration of Independence it is you
know a very beautiful thing and the most
beautiful thing of its kind ever it is
for Americans a sacred thing it does
contain mentions of God four times with
enormous reverence and what's so
beautiful about the document is it is an
assertive document they write to the
most powerful man on the face of the
earth and they say to that man we are
not going to in Bay you any further in
fact you are misguided about something
we are your equals but they are and then
at the end they pledged and remember
it's so important that they pledged to
each other their soldiers in this room
and airmen and sailors and and on the
internet - and what do you learn about
battle it a lot of people know it in
these days because we've been in so many
Wars lately soldiers come to fight for
each other and the founders mutually
pledge to each other their fortunes
their lives and their sacred honor but
they don't begin that way they actually
begin the document in the opposite sense
it is so radically impersonal that it is
specifically universal when in the core
of human events that means any time not
our time any time it becomes necessary
for one people that means any people not
just us here not just us here talking
about ourselves right to dissolve the
political bands into that have connected
them with another and to assume among
the powers of the earth the separate and
equal station to which the laws of
nature and of nature's God entitle them
is that not beautiful you see and that
means I am announcing to you George on
pain of my life that before I take any
step there is a standard before which I
must bow and by the way so must you and
that means that whatever power comes to
me and my friends after this from you to
us we will be responsible to use it in
accordance with this and it is the
specific idea of progressivism that we
have to forget about that because there
is no a binding standard there is only
the standard that we create as we go and
so first power second the deliberation
what to do about it
and I just submit that that is dangerous
I'm gonna read it later maybe but I'll
read it now because it fits so well with
where I just got to a plain proof that I
don't know what I'm doing
someone authoritative in American
politics today writes implicit in the
Constitution structure in the very idea
of ordered Liberty was a rejection of
absolute truth the infallibility of any
idea or ideology or theology any
tyrannical consistent the consistency
that might lock future generations into
a single unalterable course does it
sound like the Declaration of
Independence or does it sound like it's
precise opposite and that is a quote
from a memoir entitled the audacity of
hope' written by the President of the
United States and so you see first power
second figure out what to do that's the
problem and without asserting because it
by the way I even don't believe it that
the people who are asserting this claim
to power and to a departure from the
most successful and most beautiful
political principles and institutions
that have ever been formed that the
people who proposed that mean good and
think that they can achieve endless good
right but RJ points out there's a
contradiction there and that
contradiction is also dangerous because
how do you define good that beautiful
and wonderful term which you know in the
first sentence of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics which by the way is
the first and also the last book ever
written about the subject of ethics
nothing better than that has ever been
done and he says every voluntary human
action of every kind seems to aim at the
good and of course the rest of the book
is this investigation to discover the
meaning of that term not to create a
meaning for that term and I'm saying
then that this systematic attempt to
depart from the meaning of our nation
and the reason behind it are both the
danger we face I want to give one
example of what changes and I'll give an
example that I happen to know so much
about because I am employed in a college
I know Kiran right I'm a teacher every
term
I know Christina and her new husband
played on our football team they're
sitting down there and so I have the job
of managing this college and it's a
wonderful job it's you know it's like
herding cats except the cats are really
smart you know and that you know you
take so much joy from it I and you know
the cats by the way it's not just the
students then there's these grown up
cats who teach them and you saw some of
the money you know you gotta heard them
too and and it's a it's a wonderful
thing to do right and and you know it's
strange about our College that its idea
of itself is to work the way it worked
in 1844 and here's what you learn about
college did you know by the way that the
word college means partnership it's like
colleague right it's something to do
together and that and so far is it
possible to give a student an
entitlement to an education that what
you learn if you teach them is any
successful teaching that has ever done
is done because they're working at every
moment that they're learning or else
they are not learning and I will tell
you quickly how I learned this I do know
a fair amount about Winston Churchill
and adore him
and think I wish you could have him
today and he was really good he just was
such a wonderful human being and I love
him very much and I know stories that
make me cry and others cry when I tell
them and now one day I told one of those
stories and I noticed somebody yawned
while I was telling it and this was not
long after I went to Hillsdale College
and became a teacher and I went home and
I was sad and my wife said what's wrong
with you I was kind of demoralized which
is not like me and I said you know I
take the most beautiful things I've ever
learned and I bore them with them
how terrible Wow and and I had to learn
better right and so I learned don't tell
them ask them and then they answer and
then you know like in my freshman class
I'm teaching the Constitution for the
first time this term we have this
mandatory cast everybody has to take on
the Constitution that means you read all
these documents that everybody's been
talking about you have to read 400 pages
that are available I think to you on the
TV in here with us
and I walked in the first day and I said
okay we started out with some reading
some Aristotle and the readings are
about the subject of politics what that
subject means and also why in nature are
you a person born to be political in the
same way that a horse is born to be a
herd animal or a bee a hive animal or a
dog to wag its tail why is that I know I
was kind of cocky when I said it and
this you know girl you know it's not
quite as tall as this podium you know
and she's every bit of 18 years old she
held up her hand darned if she didn't
tell me it was shocking oh wow really
you know she's a freshman it was just
too good and so I gathered myself her
name is Sarah she might be watching and
I gathered myself it took a minute you
know I was put off and I said oh I know
I said I remembered what to do so I
disagreed with what she said and it took
me a good 10 minutes to make her
uncertain right but I I needed to do
that right because it's not enough that
I know that she has to know that and
also this is an academic institution it
requires to be argued and proved so far
as can be and that means by the way that
a college is a place where a bunch of
people get together and cooperate toward
a common goal and I can tell you
something else you cannot run it by
rules you have to run it by goals
because the young so resent the rules
and in the beginning of the country by
the way there was this massive subsidy
of colleges given first through the
Northwest Ordinance and then later
through the land-grant colleges Act and
this subsidy was to reserve
a portion of the western lands which is
about as great an asset as any
government ever owned to to benefit
education in each Township so the
federal government gave that subsidy and
then its involvement ended and as it
gave it it announced the grand purpose
of Education which I will Pete to you
from the third of the organic for
organic laws of the United States of
America article 3 of the Northwest
Ordinance which says religion morality
and knowledge being necessary to good
government and the happiness of mankind
schools and the means of education shall
ever be encouraged and I can tell you
something there's no college in America
more than a hundred years old that is
not founded with something like that in
its founding statement and there is
almost no college that is run today
according to principles that agree with
religion morality and knowledge but that
beautiful statement was the end of the
federal involvement and then people in
their localities mostly in their
townships but secondarily in their
states had to take over doing this thing
which depends absolutely decisively upon
the people in the room at the time that
it is being done and today there are
these subsidies of education that are
not as large as those first ones and
they are accompanied by several hundred
pages of rules that cannot be read and I
will tell you how I know that I did try
to read them but first I did wants to
call our lawyer when I first got deals
and I said I want you to send me title
four of the Higher Education Act and
he's a DC lobbyist in education whose
job is to keep them from giving us any
money
cos it cost quite a bit to do that and
and he said no I said there's no use in
my sending it to you and I said why and
he said well you won't be able to read
it I said really you know and he's and
you know I I was cocky you know I you
know I'm a pretty smart guy I can read
you know and I've read a lot of
complicated books and I love them and
what are you a lawyer this point was no
I can't read it either
right we keep a specialist here to read
it by the way how could you form a
partnership around a thing like that it
is out of bounds on its face it is
ridiculous
right but that is the point the
administrative state is top-down and
seeks to uniform eyes everything and to
subject everything to the will of a
person scientifically trained at the top
and remote from the activity Winston
Churchill in this wonderful essay which
I put on the readings because it's so
great called mass effects on modern life
writes the darkest sentence he ever
wrote maybe which is a description of
the Bolshevik state which he says is by
the way only taking to extreme the
tendency of modern government and he
says it reduces everything to the
condition not of the Beehive because it
cannot produce any honey it produces it
to the condition that it reduces it as a
condition of the white ant and then he
turned so you see treat us like matter
because by the way if we are evolving
things produced by time and circumstance
aren't we material creatures then not
with a immaterial and divine disposal
you see it is like we're matter governed
by instinct and the way the animals are
but then in the next most hopeful things
it is the glory and the safeguard of
mankind that they are forever easy to
lead and hard to drive
what's going on in America right now
easy to lead and hard to drive I have a
few recommendations how am i doing
I'll go fast I recommend that we don't
argue from the Constitution but for it
toward it we are in service to it it's
like a dynamite weapon right I very much
believe that everything we should be do
should be done in the name of the
Constitution but organized arguing with
ordinary people start with the stuff
they know and what do they know they got
their families they got their lives
they're responsible for them they got to
take care of them
remind them that they have a right to do
that alongside their obligation and tell
them that the thing that they notice and
that is that the government is becoming
big and expensive and intrusive and
unaccountable and inefficient which is
its reputation by the way almost a
consensus in the country right and that
the proof of that is look at politicians
from both parties and both you know the
conservative liberal spectrum they all
complain about bureaucracy it's by the
way one of the reasons why we can't have
a perfect repeat of the Great Depression
and the New Deal because when those
things happen by the way people didn't
have any experience with big government
now they do they don't like it start
with that because by the way if you want
to get rid of that that's gonna be
really hard maybe impossible but perish
the thought that it is but there is this
blessing and that is if you don't like
that thing that you see remember that
there's this little manual that we have
and it is the greatest document ever
produced to provide for centralized
government for centralized purposes and
decentralized administration for nearly
every purpose what have we worked out
with ourselves back to that and that
brings me to my second point we should
look for politicians who say that is
what they are doing and can speak
intelligently about the point
and we have to make ourselves a judge of
speak intelligently which brings me to
the next point which is we need to be
students time for us to read and think
and by the way there's so much of that
going on this is young big number of
people watching this deal and there's a
bunch of us boring old guys talking all
day long and people are listening good
thank you
and it's not us you know it's this stuff
we're talking about because it's
beautiful and great and we have to learn
to love that and we have to discipline
ourselves by that by the way because
James Madison you know when he wrote the
Constitution he had already had the
experience of Princeton of training
himself how long he needed to sleep and
what he does take an hour a week away
until he fell over and then he added an
hour back so then and he could you know
operate at peak assist consistence or
effectiveness and for long times and he
read dozens of books and he was smarter
than we are at least me and and so we
have a humility about it we should study
we should give ourselves to the job of
learning about it and so many do now
thank God for that and we should look
for politicians who show that same
humility politicians by the way should
not use the I word all the time you know
you know who didn't do that to name
three George Washington didn't do that
go read his speeches Abraham Lincoln
didn't do that Winston Churchill you
know people think he was cocky cuz he
was kinda it turns out in the end he was
a humble man read his speeches and I'm
just saying those guys were pretty good
you know and they didn't go around
bragging about themselves all the time
and I you know I'm not referring to
anybody in particular when I say that
simple laws i made a challenge once to
some friends of mine in Washington I
held up the Higher Education Act of 2007
reauthorization which is one of those
thousand-page deals that you can't read
and nobody did and I held up another
complicated law one of the most
beautiful laws ever written a a law that
deployed enormous amounts of land in the
western states into private hands it's
called the Homestead Act it was a fight
it was signed by Aaron Lincoln in 1862
and I said you know I know you guys can
write stuff like this it's a miracle you
can do it's like a dog walking on hind
legs it doesn't look very good but wow
he can do it at all it's amazing but
could you write this four-page thing I
said I made a dear to them because
they're good people you know I said look
if you could do it in a week I know you
can do this in a week if you can do this
in a week I'll give you a thousand bucks
of my money I didn't have to pay Madison
in 62nd federalists it will be of little
avail to the people that the laws are
made by men of their own choice if the
laws be so voluminous that they cannot
be read or so incoherent that they
cannot be understood if they be repealed
to revise before they are promulgated or
undergo such incessant changes that no
man who knows what the law is today
knows what it will be tomorrow right
James and you know James Madison you
think he's not better than these guys
who are running things today
he was good you know I mean cosmically
good wonderfully good what I got the
father of the Constitution and his
advice is keep it simple we should
demand that because remember there's a
relationship if sovereignty is in the
constitutional majority then the bosses
are outside the government and they
should do their work in a way that is
comprehensible
commitment should be extracted for that
and this talk of the complex society and
how infinitely blahblah everything
changes so fast I can tell you nobody
who knows how to run a company today
doesn't know that the rule is push
Authority down as far as you can all the
successful companies say that and B & B
run things by goals and not by detailed
rules and by the way you know an
institution that has run that way today
the Marine Corps and the rest of the
services - and you know they're good at
what they do I'm on the others you met
Karen Vinson I'm on the board of the
Army War College and I had dinner with a
bunch of Colonels you know one night
I've done it several times and and after
the dinner we just talked you know it
was so much fun and they're so inspiring
and such great people and by the way
like Madison they all know how long they
need to sleep down to the minute the
test all the time get the most out of
themselves and I said as I was leaving
we were leaving I stood up and I said I
have a toast to make it to you people
and they said what's that and I said I
have learned something tonight
and they said what I said do not make
the mistake of getting into a war with
you guys that won't go well you see so
the point is this complex you know gosh
it's all so confusing and everything so
tangled and we got to run so much make
it simple then everybody can cooperate
to get it done that's how a college
works that's what a college means
finally we should have a plan
we need policies that will lead us back
by simple and understandable steps and
meanwhile I won't scare the horses and
disrupt the society toward
constitutional rule and limited
government and that's going to take a
lot of thinking
once Churchill in a great moment he was
upset about the trench warfare in World
War one and that they were sitting
around in the cabinet talking about how
gloriously young men were and how they
you know we gave him a speech about the
cause of victory and church will put his
fist down on the table and he offended
everybody of course he had this gift for
doing that and he said those brave young
men that you send out every day
perishing ten thousand a day they
actually have a cause already they don't
need you for that they need a plan so we
need to be working on a plan and the
plan should be simple I have an item to
suggest to go in the plan we have a debt
problem and it's in the arithmetic of
the world that there's two ways to pay
debt and one way one way is to pay it
out of income that means taxes and the
other way is to make what we call in
accounting I used to study accounting
and undergraduate school a balance sheet
transaction you could trade assets for
debt guess how the Revolutionary War
debt was paid sold land in fact the
urgent wish was to get the land into
private hands as rapidly as possible
because that was understood to be in the
public interest after they paved the
debt by selling the land then in the
Homestead Act they started giving it
away and remember about the giving it
away provision that the land was given
away that couldn't have just been a
political deal because most of it was
not yet States and so that meant that
the congressmen who put through the
Homestead Act didn't do it to get
reelected it seemed like the right thing
that people should own some
and sell the dang land and by the way we
own more land than we used to because if
you look at map shaded in the United
States a public versus private land if
you look in the east it's all private
and as you go farther west it becomes
more and more public until you get to
Alaska and Nevada where there's hardly
any private land why because it was
settled in a time when the principles
had changed and it was thought that the
public interest was served by public
ownership I think we should take that on
and I think rather than paying all those
taxes we should sell a lot of asset
cities you know they're broke now are
selling assets like roads and toll roads
and stuff like that to get money we
should sell assets for debt but we
should think of other things like that
which don't have to be fundamentally
disruptive that can be simply understood
and by the way that idea needs a lot of
work and I'm a school teacher what if we
look for politicians who were thinking
about stuff like that and who are
creative at thinking up ideas to get us
back toward the goal because that too is
a decentralized tax task where a lot of
people have to get together to pursue
the task so as I say then if you could
get the ends right and the ends are
controversial and the controversy is
simple to stay
is it true as it says in the Declaration
of Independence that there is such a
thing as a nature of man is it true that
under that nature no man may be governed
by another man as any man may be
governed by a horse if that was true
then it is true now if it is not true
now it was not true then and that means
by the way that the progressives cannot
claim as they say reasonably that their
principles are a development on the
revolutionary principles they are a
rejection of them and they must be
because they are logically and mutually
exclusive that's the first part of the
controversy and the second is shall we
have the government structures that fit
those first principles or these new
principles and if we adopt the first and
we must work our way back toward
constitutional rule and once we agree
about the ends then the means will begin
to come into shape and that is the
substance of our task after we can agree
about the ends so it seems to me then
that this revival requires some thinking
and I will promise you all that at
Hillsdale College we will be doing that
thinking because it is in our charter to
do it from 1844 and we have not
abandoned that and we shall not accept
by force and it will take a lot of force
thank you all very much
thank you very much dr. Arnn we have
time now for plenty of questions again
if you're viewing this at home please
feel free to email us at Kirby Center at
Hillsdale VDU our first question comes
from Paul from Modesto California
could you please paint a picture of what
America might look and feel like today
if we had not followed the path of
becoming an administrative state
everybody'd be better looking well
remember by the way that heaven doesn't
happen here on earth and there'll always
be a lot of trouble human vice is what
it is and people are imperfect my wife
is a help to me in that regard so don't
think that there'll be nirvana but you
know I think we'd probably be a lot
richer I think that if you look at the
good things in the country today the
things that I think are the best things
the American gift is self actuation
charity you know by the way we are the
most philanthropic people on the face of
the earth there's really nobody it's a
difference in kind really from others
the amount of giving and care for our
communities and so a lot of stuff would
be handled at the local level the
country has become very wealthy and
that's you know partly to do with
technology but not really because the
greatest growth story in history of any
country is not China today it's the
United States in the 19th century and
that was before the dawn of such rapid
advances in technology although there
were something what really happened
there was they managed to delegate to
people the management of their lives and
the ownership of their property and so I
think the economy would do very well in
such a thing especially if the federal
government did the things it's very much
supposed to do for the economy like to
name some forgotten ideas
sound money secure contracts light
burden of government equal laws strong
national defense you know stuff like
that
so I think you could get a richer
country but that's not the main thing
people thrive when it's delegated to
them that is to say the natural thing
they own which is the right to live
shouldn't attempt to live well is mainly
in their hands and I think there'd be
improvement if you had that this
question comes from Ted in Bismarck
North Dakota we know what Churchill did
in the Second World War but what did
Churchill think about progressives and
progressivism Churchill was he was a
great man and McKinney's life he
conceived his life to be a struggle
against the same problem at home and
abroad
these various forms of virulent
historicists thought so he was an anti
socialist very powerful one in the same
way that he was a a anti-nazi in an
anti-communist he said in 1945 that the
Socialist Party with which he had been
in coalition during the war could not
achieve its ultimate aims without the
use of a secret police and then he
mentioned a Gestapo very strong words
right and he was at that time that sort
of greatest man in the world and that
was controversial and the solfege
socialists beat him in the election I
don't I think that's what he thought and
I think he thought it all his life
Churchill was in favor of social welfare
policy things that are some of them not
unlike the things we're debating today
and and I think that takes some
understanding I know that he and he said
very much that he feared the growth of
bureaucracy and I think that we're in
the realm of prudence there especially
as regards England because England
doesn't
our constitutional system right it's not
it's the first was not a written
constitution Churchill wrote a wonderful
1936 essay about that called what good
is a constitution in which he compares
the British in the America and he gives
very high praise to both and says that
are the fixity of ours is an advantage
with some disadvantages too but you
should keep it so I think you know first
of all Churchill lived a long time ago
and he's dead now so to say what he
would think about stuff right now is the
doubtful task but I can tell you what he
thought about related stuff in his life
and I just did and I think he'd be very
worried today about bureaucracy because
he was in his own time and it's much
larger now than it was them
and I think he would is very much an
anti socialist and that's not really
what especially in America what the
progressives ever called themselves they
have a more fluid set of purposes with
some of the same ideas in mind and I
think he would oppose that because he
did in his lifetime but I add the caveat
that there are some things today that I
am very much against that he was for and
I think about that a lot this question
comes from mark West Palm Beach Florida
I am foreign-born and American by choice
what Ken or should we do to change the
sad state of our public school system
which has failed and its responsibility
to educate its students in American
history its Constitution and the
American identity my father is a public
school teacher all his life and I went
to the public schools until I got to
graduate school and the Northwest
Ordinance sort of sets them up so fixing
them seems to me like a really good
thing and I think there's a couple
things wrong with them one of them is
they've in very considerable extent got
the wrong idea their idea now is you
know if you look at the AP guide to
secondary literature that's a you know
you know what advanced placement courses
look them up if you don't know what they
are but you probably do it's a very
influential thing in education and what
that guide says about literature is is
that objectivity and factual
or out the door now we teach students to
find their own reality in the text no
doubt hoping they will find values to
guide them through a mad mad world
that's a quote you know pretty close and
you can the thing you know it's almost
exactly what it says and and the point
about that is that deprives the kid of
the reason to read the book you know and
little wonder they don't read it but
then also so another that's that's
related to the phenomenon they don't the
basics of what you should learn by the
way in life my own opinion is you don't
really ever get very much beyond the
basics they've become more beautiful to
you as you go and eventually they become
a wonderfully elevated thing I'd focus
on that and then I would decentralize
them because remember you don't run much
very well by top-down rules and so the
high school were my dad talked Todd I
know happened to know I know maybe I
don't sound like it I don't know but I
know a lot of grammar and the reason is
we had this fierce mean old teacher
named mr. Amos in Pocahontas Arkansas
his daughter is I still know he's both
his daughters he passed away not long
ago and he was just meaner and hack
right
he should be liberated to do that and by
the way I don't know grammar because
somebody passed a rule in Little Rock
Arkansas or Washington DC Mr Amos he was
the mean guy he's the important person
organize it like that our next question
will be from our studio audience sir
Gary Meredith Fairfax Virginia hi hi I
know this is being broadcast and
recorded and archived so I want to start
with a disclaimer that I'm not
advocating the overthrow of the federal
government
but but on the other hand we we are now
subjected to government which passes
rules regulations laws and intrusions in
our lives for which they can cite no
authority at what point at what point do
the people say your rules laws
regulations are not are not binding that
we are under no obligation to follow
them
that's good question now you're going to
be recorded that's a that's um so so
first of all not this point you know we
have elections in this country we should
focus on them and the law we should try
to have the rule of law and respected
ourselves I'll tell you an example by
the way to help you answer your question
Gary and we happen to know in that we're
just going through this in my class
right now in the steps leading up to the
Declaration of Independence there was
enormous doubt about what to do and it
seemed like a mighty big step to declare
independence from the King of England
and people of very good conscience and
individual people inside themselves
didn't know what to do right and the
Declaration of Independence says about
that as a guide that when a long train
of abuses evinces a design to reduce
them to an absolute despotism it says
that that's your standard and it says
before that prudence indeed will dictate
that government will not be changed for
light or transient causes and our
government is such a great thing that we
should be very reluctant very more
reluctant than anyone one was to rebel
against the King of England because this
is a better government than the one that
George the third was running but I will
tell you that if you follow those steps
along you know you've read your daniel
Delaney and you read your james otis and
then you get to you're in our reader
then you get to a summary view of the
rights of British North America and then
now at last Thomas Jefferson is right
and the first team is on the field he
could write and and he lays it out for
the King really good and that's a step
along the way along with compaines
common sense toward the revolution and I
don't think we're gonna get there and I
pray that we do not very earnestly but I
think if we did get there we would want
to be as reasonable and high-minded and
self-restrained
as the people who made our first
revolution and that's a long way down
the road and as I say one prays not to
go there and if he got there how could
we ever do it so well as it was done the
first time the next question comes from
an online participant Raj from Trenton
New Jersey how can we get back to an
ethic or code of responsibility we have
a bill of rights but what about a bill
of Duty's it seems strange to talk like
that but how can we start talking about
duties and responsibilities in a way
that others can understand well the
answer to that is contained in a quick
google search I go find Ronald Reagan's
first inaugural address it's a model of
the type and remember in this regard
that America is in one sense a very old
country the oldest country ever because
it's constitutional history is so
continuous compared to any previous
example especially any example of a
written constitution and so Reagan
stands up in 1981 and he does what every
president has done which took the same
oath and turn around and make a speech
of roughly the same length and his is a
model it begins by the point about
self-government two points really the
first thing he does by the way is demote
himself in the first paragraph it says
roughly yeah for some of us today this
is a momentous occasion he's talking
about himself and his family and his
friends but of course in the life of the
nation it's a regular event that's one
of the glories of the nation he says and
that great
and then he says this economy's in a
god-awful mess and we're not gonna fix
it you're gonna fix it right then down
farther he turns you know because by the
way the first person to have it back on
the west or back into the capital
looking at the National Mall was Reagan
and Obama is the second and Reagan did
it to take us on a tour of the monuments
and he spoke of this wonderful respect
to the founders you know who in George
Washington who in his humility had the
courage to found the nation of Lincoln
whoever will understand the meaning of
America will find it in the life of that
man and then in the final stage he grows
across the river and he points at the
crosses and Stars of David before each
one planted a hero like these men I've
mentioned in other words every one of
them like George Washington and Abe
Lincoln and Thomas Jefferson and then he
picks out his first hero who happens to
be a man named Martin truck tow and he
says of him he was in the rainbow
division and one of the first Americans
killed in the expeditionary force and he
reached from this man's diary and this
man says we must men win this war and I
must do my part as if the whole result
depends on me now you want to know why
this peaceful democratic commercial
republic produces soldiers like nobody
because in our country we get the habits
of competition and cooperation of a free
people and so our armies get on the
field and they just figure it out and do
it and also they are possessed in their
souls with the idea that it is their
cause and they are responsible for it
and all of the great high moments in
American political history contain are
blessed with somebody who can articulate
that point and it echoes in the breasts
of every American
Don from San Diego California asks
you've mentioned several readings that
we should look to to understand the
Constitution better can you give us a us
ordinary Americans a short list of books
that would help us in our attempt to
grow in our appreciation and
understanding of the Constitution well
you should everybody should read that
constitution reader which I you know I
didn't think that up I've been adding to
it a little bit lately because pride
makes me do it but you know there's a
collection of people around our College
who and there you know there has been
for a long time but lately there's a
kind of revival of that who really have
thought very deeply about that and that
reader is a product of an understanding
of the movements of American history and
remember a feature of it is we love the
Constitution we read the people who
posted
we love the Union we work at an
abolitionist college right had a big
part in the Civil War we read the
thinkers of the Old South we don't like
the progressive movement we teach them
by reading it's key authors so that's
how you learn if you learn fair and true
and stand up ready to make the argument
I admitted something about Winston
Churchill that probably nobody listened
to this new but I had to tell you the
truth about it that he was in favor of a
lot of this stuff we're talking about
today for Britain and I can read those
circumstances to you and I can put an
argument together about why that was and
why that doesn't apply here but the
facts got to be admitted all the same so
I'd start with that and then I don't
believe you got to read Aristotle if you
want to know what politics are you got
to read the list of books that Jefferson
said you should read in a letter to
Madison if I remember where it came the
elemental books of public right he named
when it wasn't a Madison Locke and
Sidney and I can't remember what they
were but Plato and Aristotle so I would
work on that and you know they're extra
from some of those things in this reader
and you know there's a curriculum at
Hillsdale College and you can get a copy
of that easy if you go to our website or
write me a note or send me an email this
will be our final question and I can
assure you that no payment was tendered
for the rendering of this question Taryn
from Lincoln Nebraska asks aside from
sending my teenager to Hillsdale College
what else can I do to help educate this
next generation of bright minds have
more teenagers learn yourself teach
others you know by the way remember if
it we think it's a miracle what's going
on right now this is the pattern the
revolution itself starts in the Great
Awakening right it's a religious
movement it's a social movement finally
it becomes a political movement finally
there's a plan the civil war fall of the
same course people talking and thinking
in their concern and fear and honesty
the best of them not claiming they know
everything but putting their arguments
together together carefully with
citations and quotes and reading and
reasoning carefully and trying to prove
what do you think the character of the
Committees of Correspondence was like
and so by the way if you are such a
person and it's only a function of how
you spend your time then you will find
that your fellow citizens will turn to
you and look at you and say wow thank
you for that and then what you tell them
is and by the way if I can do it anybody
can do it I can say that personally
thank you all very much
thank you very much dr. Arnn before we
adjourn for the day I just wanted to
make a couple of brief announcements
that is that if you are watching this at
home and missed one or more of the
presentations they will be by this
evening available in an archival form if
you have caught the entirety of it but
you'd like to tell your friends family
or colleagues about the program they can
register starting this evening to watch
the program at Constitution townhall.com
also to those of you who have registered
and to anybody else who's interested
just write us a drop us an email and
we'll send notice out to all of those of
you who did register about the DVDs the
DVDs for this Constitution Town Hall
will be available soon and we'll be sure
to send you word about when they are
available
in addition we'd encourage you to visit
the the two websites that we've
mentioned throughout the day Hillsdale
edu and also the Kirby center.org George
Washington said the Constitution is that
which he never will abandon it's the
guide that he will never abandon we join
him in today making that pledge and
appreciate your participation in this
Constitution Town Hall have a great day